so it might be the luckiest person on
earth because I just got to interview at
a festival recently a real NASA
astronaut someone who's been to space
not once but twice and she spent over
three months up there living on the
International Space Station doing all
kinds of experiments Oh she also lived
under the sea for a while
she's probably the coolest person I've
ever had the opportunity to speak to now
I just want to precursor it with for
some reason I didn't decide to record
our conversation until the very last
minute so I literally just saw someone
hey can I bring a camera and just set it
up there so the image quality is not
very good the sounds not great either
the camera even shuts off halfway
through for like five minutes so I've
had to do some weird editing but it
doesn't matter the point is I'm talking
with an astronaut about her life and all
the cool things that she does so check
it out I hope you enjoy it thank you so
much for joining us Nicole that's a
really interesting transition going sort
of from being a scientist for your whole
career to an artist how do you find
these two schools of thought work
together well I personally think there's
no conflict between the two and I don't
know in the simplest way I like to think
about and I try to tell my son too is
that you need to use your whole brain
and so to me the the art and the science
the art and like Spacey kinds of things
technical things all come together so
nicely and I also think and you
mentioned that when I retired I went on
to do this art work of my own and
working with some other people I think
that art is this it's like a universal
communicator whether it's music or
paintings or you know or sculpture you
can engage with audiences that you might
not be able to otherwise
and certainly
me and wanting to share the spaceflight
experience I know there's a lot of
people out there that don't even know we
have a space station so if I can use my
art and then as a way to lure them and
whether they like it or not you know
whether they really I think my art is
any good or not but if I can lure them
in with it and then share that backstory
I'm having flown in space and what we're
doing in space that's all about
improving life on Earth I think that's a
really good thing why is it so important
because I mean obviously you've had the
unique experience of seeing the Earth
from space what is there like a specific
perspective or some feeling that you got
from that that you feel is important to
to let others know about yeah definitely
and I think anybody who's had that
opportunity feels the same way they may
want to express it a little bit
differently but nothing prepared me for
what I saw and felt when I looked out at
the window and saw Earth from space I
think you know I was separated further
away from the planet in a way than I
ever would probably be again in my life
and yet I felt more connected to
everything and everyone below me then I
had write down in the middle of it and I
think that happens to us you know
perhaps like at this festival people are
separating themselves they're looking at
things from a new perspective and and
appreciating things in a different way
we do a lot of really complex things in
space whether it's how we get there how
we live there the science we're doing
and yet when I came home from space
there were three very simple lessons
that that seemed to go along with it for
me and that's that we live on a planet
we're all earthlings and the only border
that matters is that thin blue line of
atmosphere that blankets us all and I
think that's something we all know
intellectually and yet I don't remember
really processing that every day and I
do now and I
we want everybody to feel that way to
think about yourself there and the fact
that you are on a planet in space with
everyone else together it's a pretty
pretty profound thing absolutely thank
you so tell us a bit about what life
what was your daily routine on the ISS
if you have such a thing did you have a
daily routine because obviously like
days they're very different there right
yeah you know there is a daily routine
and I'll just start you know with where
you said that like days are very
different we still work to a 24-hour
clock just like we went down here on
earth we work to what I think is your
local time to GMT which makes it nice
for the people on the planet to have a
standard and for us to as you can
imagine though you know we're going
around the earth 16 times a day five
miles a second you know 17,500 miles an
hour so in every 90 minutes so every 45
minutes or so we get this beautiful
sunrise or sunset out the window so you
can't really use you know day/night as
your gauge for you know for the time
passing and so we work off of the
timeline that's given to us from the
ground really following along on the
computer and then you know your belly
tells you when you're hungry your head
tells you when you're tired
and you kind of get him into a routine
that way but otherwise every day is
different
and that's one of the things I really
loved about it it's because every day
there was a mix of science and
maintenance and outreach activities like
this speaking to people on the ground
but it was always a different mix of
those things and on top of it you know
because we can't fly as many people yet
we can't fly the medical doctor and the
electrician and the scientist we are all
of those people and so we're doing
something different every day and
to get you know everything from fixing
the toilet to doing some research
activity for a scientist on the ground
which is really cool so imagine your
training must have almost covered
everything but yeah anything that
happened that really surprised you or
any experience they had I think there
was a lot that surprised me because you
know we do
yeah our training is really really good
one thing I will say about it is you
know we do training and all these
simulators on the ground because sadly
you can't fly in space to learn how to
fly in space yet and I was so pleased to
find that when I floated from the Space
Shuttle on to the space station it felt
familiar you know except that I was
floating yeah
it's familiar even the smells were kind
of the same and you know what I expected
to see and here was kind of the same so
that was nice but there were loads of
surprises too because for instance
there's nothing that we do down here on
earth that can really prepare you for
what it feels like to flew in space to
the fly to be liberated that way it's
just amazing it was like I said there's
nothing that prepares you for that view
out the window just how stunning and
glowing and colorful the earth is and
the fact that you realize we're on a
planet that's that's pretty impressive
and I would say there were things like
the smell of the space that nobody had
told me about and that's not that you
can float out the you know the hatch and
take your helmet off and smell space but
that would be bad but when things would
come into the space station that had
been exposed to space they all had
kind of this sweet metallic smell but
nobody had told me about and that's
whether it was like a spacesuit
you know after doing a spacewalk or the
hatch of a new vehicle that had docked
it all all had this really interesting
not bad but kind of interesting smell
what do you think close that is there
some kind of sort of chemical process
going on in there deep recession or hey
you know I don't really know nobody has
really told me but what I've heard is
like maybe a reaction with like atomic
oxygen and the different materials and
you know who knows but it was cool it
was very interesting to see that that
was what regardless of what it was it
had that smell Wow and then I think
there was one thing that I really really
wasn't prepared for was you know looking
out the windows it was a night past it
was night down on earth and that's
always really beautiful and I was by
myself in the window and I saw this you
know flash of light go by and oh my gosh
yeah what was that and of course you
always get the alien question I can tell
you not that I know of didn't see
anything as far as I know they make it
see me I don't know but so I see this
flash of light and I thought my gosh
what was that was really beautiful and
so I float down ask my crewmates now I
got shooting star you'll know you'll see
him every now and then below you I was
like wow you know go back to the window
and like we do when we're down here on
earth you know when I see a shooting
star at night looking up in the sky I
want to see another one so I'm in the
window like watch to see another one and
of course there's not another one and I
just stopped there for a little while
thinking about it again like nobody told
me about this it was this really
beautiful surprise and then I remember
thinking wow you know I'm really glad I
saw that because that means it didn't
hit my spaceship which could've been a
real happy
don't want a new patient oh yeah lots of
surprises
what was some of the experiments you
were working on Molly with that Wow we
had and there's even more now I think we
were their crew 6 we had about 150 to
200 different research activities going
on at any different time on the space
station and some of those were very
actively involved and we're actually the
experiment you know the wire some some
way to see if we still have a brain have
a heart and how that's changing in space
and then pretty much any area of science
that you could think of there was
something going on there there were you
know protein crystal growth experiments
looking at you know different vaccines
and you know how to create medicines
that are more effective because you can
build those crystal structures in the
microgravity environment more
practically than we can down here on
earth there were combustion experiments
we had this combustion chamber so cool
that inside it every day where there was
these different mixtures of fuels
burning and things that burn in space
they burn like a sphere not like the
kind of a teardrop like we see down here
and so that allows the scientists to
look at the interaction between the
different components in a new way and
you know discover ways to have fuel to
pollute less or more you know more
efficient and and I think the thing that
you know is really exceptional about it
to me is that it's two things one is
that we go to space because we can take
gravity out of the equation and we can
look at these things we thought we knew
all about in a whole new way and
discover new things about them and to is
that every bit of science every bit of
the way we built the space station and
how we're working together as
international partners up there
everything about it is ultimately about
improving life here on earth and I think
that's a really cool thing to be a part
of is that one particular experiment
that
done yet that you would love to see
happen oh wow that hasn't been done I
don't know I was reading recently that
we haven't we haven't figured out
whether mammals are able to reproduce in
space example I was really surprised to
hear that you know they're heard as far
as I know they haven't put mat mice in
space for example right any animal has a
sort of short gestation period we've had
you know we've had the animals in space
we actually took I flew the first time
we took up six mice on the space shuttle
and then I took care of them all we were
up there and then we brought them back
on my ride home and I'll tell you just
as as cool as we are as as creatures you
know in the way our bodies and our
brains adapt to new environments these
little mice do the same thing I mean
they just got it when they up to space
they just figured out how to make you
know we're doing their thing I don't
know that we've and I don't think we've
done any reproductive experiments in
space where we actually you know have
the animal and they're pregnant or go
through that cycle
none of that do I know of there may be
you know some embryonic stuff that's
been done I think it's because we just
don't know yet how how that's gonna work
and I think there's you know there's a
epical things around that and just in
the way we have animals on the station
and in space that I'm thankful we're
we're thoughtful about it
so as a poker player I pretty used to
learn some lessons
giving it talk tomorrow you can listen
and know so you know Sam used to risk
and so on but you're dealing with risk
on a whole other level you know you
there's an inherent risk to life in not
only spaceflight but also unit
spacewalks what you know what you sort
of assumed you were told of the
probabilities of death inherent in your
in your missions were you were aware of
them if so what were they and how did
you sort of manage that risk internally
in your mind yeah I think I was told the
numbers I honestly don't remember them
now they're not hot I mean they're high
in terms of the risk they're not high in
terms you know the safety of it I think
anybody who does this knows there's this
inherent risk to it but I think it comes
back to what I was saying before about
what we're doing there and the value of
it and I can tell you when I flew the
first time my son was seven years old I
cannot imagine strapping on to a rocket
with seven million pounds of rocket
thrust you know underneath you and just
doing it for the fun or for the
adventure of it I can tell you it's fun
and it's adventurous but if there wasn't
some element of in fact if the majority
of the reason wasn't associated with
some element of greater good and and
that's what went through my mind is is
what I'm going to do in space going to
benefit my son in his future and I know
that it does I that was the rationale
for me was that you know what we're
doing there is about creating a better
future for everyone and on top of that
you know I worked very closely in one of
my first jobs with NASA at the Kennedy
Space Center with the people who build
and maintain and take care of and who
honestly believe the care and feeding of
the spacecraft is their responsibility
and I don't think there was anything
more than that that you can do besides
getting the numbers to understand you
know kind of that risk reward and I
really feel like the reward is
significantly outweighs the risk that
that we have going on the spaceflight
did you have any who's that like one
particularly scary moment or anything
that happened well we had on the space
station I would say they were coffee
three or four times where I remember
being woken up in the middle of the
night it always happens like three
o'clock in the morning right and you
know the emergency alarm is going off
and and of course when we when we train
for emergencies in space we there's a
lot of things that can avert you kill
you cause problems but we focus on three
things as emergencies and that's fire
toxic atmosphere so like ammonia highly
concentrated ammonia getting into the
environment or depressurization which is
why I would worry about that shooting
star hitting my spaceship and putting a
big hole in it so all the air goes
spewing out into the vacuum of space and
three or four times had one of those
emergency alarms go off in the middle of
the night and I can tell you it gets
your adrenaline pumping certainly but I
found it it was in a good way and I
think that's because all the training
that we've done as a crew in responding
almost all of our training and one way
or another is about how do you work as a
team and how do you work as a team when
it's hit in a band which it will and I
was so pleased to see how 3 o'clock in
the morning everyone floats out of their
apartment we make sure we have all crew
members you know accounted for we all
then disperse and do what we trained to
do on the ground and we do it like we
did on
Brown Andhra treatment like it's real
until it's resolved and that was a
really reassuring thing because when
stuff was going on that was
communicating to you that something real
is happening there's a fire there's a
depressurization that's the kind of
people you want to be with you want to
be with them when you're having fun and
enjoy it but you want to know that
you're all going to rally for each other
in a way that you know takes care of the
situation and thankfully we didn't have
anything that caused us to have to
evacuate the station or that caused any
harm to us or or to the station in a way
that compromise the mission so yeah that
was a good thing so going from the
extreme vacuum of space you went to the
other extreme you you know you went
under the sea for 18 days in this
high-pressure environment
I in hindsight found that I felt the
same way from that experience about you
know seeing the earth around me it's
like I was surrounded by the planet you
know in that case versus in space kind
of being the one that's surrounding it
you know above it and looking down at
the same kind of perspective as I have
in space of this is you know this is the
planet and we're all on it and it's here
and purposely built to allow me to
survive and so really was a really great
thing and then coming up I felt like you
know I felt like I could have stayed
down there a lot longer
it was certainly he's like I was the one
in the in the aquarium and all the fish
and the creatures they are like hey
who's in there now you know and you got
to be part of you know that scene there
with you know with these creatures that
are in their natural home and we or not
and the same is true in space although I
didn't see any creatures out the window
so we're sad to see a I find it very
exciting and a renewed space race but
instead of it being between countries as
it was a few decades ago it's now
between private companies with Blue
Origin and SpaceX you know seemingly
taking space technology to new to new
levels some curious to know what your
thoughts on this you are their pros and
cons and how do you feel about this a
privatization of space no way
yeah I'm you know excited about it you
know I'm here on the west coast of
Florida so I see these launches going
off on the East Coast and it's really
cool to know that all this is building
up again
I think the interesting thing right now
is that we're not quite at a stage of
privatization we're at a partnership
stage where they're kind of this
public-private thing going on and a
little bit different way I mean we've
always had that even when we went to the
moon or we built the Space Shuttle or
the Space Station we've always as NASA
as as the government has always worked
with private companies to make these
things happen
now we're just doing it in a way where
instead of NASA owning the spaceship
afterwards the company does and then
they have the flexibility to develop
other business models and do other
things with it that you know expand
beyond what NASA is a government agency
could do and I think that's really
exciting
the downside to me of anything is that
we need to make sure that we don't reel
in the same lessons we already learned
before because you know because we have
companies or people or organizations
working that didn't have that same
experience and we need to leverage all
of those lessons learned because there's
so much out there that could hurt us
that we don't know about its associated
with that risk of flying in space that
we don't need to learn the same things
over again yeah I mean to me it feels
like it's sort of using the best bits of
capitalism
yeah yeah I'm really really excited
about this and upon seeing how we fly on
airplanes the way we do now
I mean it's that same kind of evolution
I think that we'll be going through yeah
absolutely
did you always want to be an astronaut
was it something you dreamed of from a
kid or did it sort of crop up in your
mind later in life well I think I always
thought it was really cool and my closet
I mean I watched the moon landing six
six six and a half years old and even
then I think you know there's something
really extraordinary about about that
going on you know walking out looking at
the moon and seeing seeing and knowing
that there's people out there for me
though it's more about flying I was
really excited about flying I wanted to
know how things fly and while I was
going to school for that at university
it kind of clicked maybe a little late
on my class you want to know how
airplanes fly why would you not want to
know how rocket ships fly and that led
me to my job with NASA as an engineer
and it really wasn't until I was working
there probably again slow like 9:00 into
the 10 years of working ahead of a Space
Center and see astronauts come through
and getting spaceships waiting for them
to fly and and figuring out that you
know 99.9 percent of an astronaut's job
sadly is not flying in space you know
and 80 percent of it was a little late
what I was already doing as an engineer
and that made me start to think that
there could be some reality associated
with the job because up till that point
I always thought you know wow this is
really cool look what they get to do but
that's some other special person that
gets to do that why would anybody think
me
and you know I second-guessed myself
almost out of the applying and I was
very thankful to a couple people that I
consider to be mentors and encouraged me
you know nothing more really than just
to pick up the pen and fill out the
application and I am very thankful to
them for the youngsters in the audience
who might be considering the coming up
an astronaut what what steps should they
be taking to improve their chances
festivals like the one you're at is
really cool I think there's there is
very much a you know kind of science and
arts by to what you guys are doing which
is it's impressive and you should expose
yourself to those kinds of things and
those kinds of people number one though
you know pay attention to what you enjoy
you know I am in awe of how just paying
attention to the fact that I liked
flying I liked I wanted to know how
things fly the opportunities that open
up and the people that you'll meet when
you pay attention to that the curiosity
that you'll develop and be encouraged by
is is really awesome
and then you know get outside of the
books too
you know you're gonna have what you have
to do at school but you need to
understand how what you're studying and
what you know what you're interested in
benefits life around you what's the real
world the reality application to what
you're doing and those are key things to
becoming an astronaut fantastic thank
you well I think it's time to open up
some questions to the audience okay lots
of hands going up already if we can get
the mic out there
[Music]
if there was one more thing that you
could go back and do what would it be
Oh in space Wow I think it would be look
at the earth a little bit more and have
you know I had the chance to paint while
I was in space I painted a watercolour
and I would love to do that again and do
it while I was floating in front of the
window I think there's something very
human to that and yeah take my family
would be good how do you keep the
paint's together but they're they fly
away yeah you know and I paint with
watercolors so it's kind of fun you
can't dip your brush into a cup of water
because there's no cups of water it's
just floating balls of water so you know
different brush and a little floating
ball where you got to keep track of
everything you know because everything
does float and there were some
interesting things about painting with
watercolors that I didn't expect so it
took a couple of tries well we have we
do have some tanks on board that you
know have oxygen and nitrogen
you know mixes that blend to do that we
have a couple systems that allow us to
to recycle you know the water the
moisture that's in our environment and
you know there's some electrolysis
things that go on that allow us to
generate the oxygen and we do still I
think replenish from the ground as well
but we're getting more and more or I
should say less and less dependent on
that which is really cool and the same
thing is true for like our drinking
water we used to send all of that up and
now we have systems that allow us to I
think like 96 to 98 percent of the like
wastewater or condensation or sweat or
urine that we can recycle into clean
drinking water which is which is really
really cool and it applies to providing
same resource to people down here on
earth to don't have it was it a very
long heat - yeah how many lines or did
you count I didn't count the lines but
you know it's a pretty lengthy
application and you know what I found
out it's kind of funny is it's the same
application that I filled out to be an
engineer with NASA - you just have to
think differently about the way you
answer the questions with respect to the
job that you're applying for
and I always try to tell people to
practice filling out that application if
they want to apply to be an astronaut
because the questions aren't always
asked the way an easy way to allow you
to give them the information you want to
give them about you like for instance
the things you do outside of work or
outside of school that make you the
person that you are and ultimately when
they pick you you know they'll know that
you've satisfied the school and the work
requirements but they want to know who
you are and how you'll work with the
people on your crew and you know will
you be somebody that I want to spend six
months on a space station with and will
I be able to trust that you'll have my
back when something goes wrong and you
know those kinds of things so I don't
know how many lines but I would say
practice filling it out if you want to
do it would you go again
I would absolutely go again I can tell
you can ask me when I'm ninety five
years old do I want to fly in space
again and the answer is is a hundred
percent yes and as you can imagine the
decision to retire from a job like that
was was difficult I was in line to fly
again so I took myself out of that line
and the way I did that was by answering
the question do I need to fly in space
again and the answer is no I didn't need
to and there were things I wanted to do
like what I the work I'm doing now with
kids and hospitals around the world
where I'm taking two things that I love
space and art and putting them together
and I think I'm on another really
rewarding mission and but yes the answer
is absolutely yes
and take me with you good to go thank
you did you prefer when you went into
space oh you went under water that's a
really difficult question I think I
think they may not be a preference thing
but it's because it's much more
difficult to get to do to go to space I
think I probably have to answer with
space but there's something really
really inspirational without seeing the
planet from underwater too and not I
kind of think of it like I was always a
recreational scuba diver and so I I've
gone diving before I've seen underwater
life and experienced it but when you get
to live there kind of be part of it on a
longer term basis there's an impression
that's made that's a little bit
different and so I would never turn down
the opportunity to go back and live on
Aquarius again to go back to the
shooting star
episode I'm wondering how we were able
to save shooting star in space I know so
so we're above the atmosphere a little
bit kind of at the far reaches of it and
so the the line of the atmosphere is
below us and so what you end up seeing
is the piece of material re-entering the
atmosphere so you don't see it until
it's much lower and below you but you
see the streak down close to Earth and
it's really really beautiful and the
thing that was was kind of boggling my
mind a little bit when I saw it was you
know our brains are so used to seeing
things in a particular way you know my
my knowledge of seeing a shooting stars
by looking up towards towards space not
looking down towards Earth and so it was
a little I mean it was like the
wildering to to be able to see something
like that it was the way you spoke about
it sort of shot past the window it was
below now that doesn't mean I mean we do
see things like tiny pieces of debris
you know small items we occasionally can
catch them out there with us and and
it's not good if it's really close to
your spaceship thing and going in the
opposite direction
you know 17,500 miles an hour head-on
would not be good even tiny little you
know things the size of sand can do
damage to the material on the outside of
the space station so we prefer not to
see that awesome question can I say
everything first of all and
and then I'll talk it off with I think
my favorite things to see on earth were
the colors in the ocean and and the
colors so I'll stop colors might be the
answer because it didn't matter if they
were in the ocean or out in the middle
of the desert there were these patterns
and colors that I just hadn't really
even imagined before and there's a
little area on the planet from the
southern tip of Florida down to like the
northern coast of South America that was
absolutely the most beautiful place I
think I'd ever seen all these blues and
turquoises and just glowing little
islands and things that really stood out
as special to me
[Music]